we'll get to our five headlines
[Music]
well the insurrectionist says we've been
discussing or swarming uh
our cities across the country again last
night i could probably stop saying that
you could just assume
that they're out there every night being
scumbags doing what
scumbags do but this incident in la
is above and beyond much of what we've
seen so far
so let's first watch the video and then
i'll describe it for those listening on
the audio podcast but
watch it right now okay so you have
there a driver trying to drive around
the rioters
who are in the middle of the street now
yes
they think we've seen this all across
the country they think that
they have the right to shut down any
street they want to
you know direct traffic they can do
whatever they want um
and if you try to it's not just it's not
if you if you run them over if you try
to just go
around them to go down a street that
they don't want you on for whatever
reason
then they think now they have every
right to uh
smash your windows assault you pull you
out of the car kill you if that's what
they decide to do
so in this case you got a driver trying
to go around the rioters
they swarm his car he successfully
escapes doesn't doesn't hit anybody
is driving away on an empty street okay
it's not like he's plowing through
uh like a bowling ball going through
rioters no he's going down an empty
street
and then what do they do they get into
cars and they
chase him in vehicles cut him off
attack the vehicle and then uh
and try to pull him out and finally at
the end we see cops show up and arrest
him
the victim so two points here
the first is that just again these
protesters are monsters
they are evil they'll they're soulless
dirt bags
the divide between good guy and bad guy
in this
situation is so clear we have rarely
seen in america a political movement
that was so
thoroughly and obviously evil with no
redeeming qualities whatsoever
blm and antifa
we're talking about one of the most evil
political movements in american history
utterly destructive violent and hateful
attacking innocent people at random
for no good reason not that it could be
a good reason but they certainly don't
have one
also pathologically dishonest they lie
about everything
their whole movement as we've already
discussed is based on
total lies and fabrications so they're a
lot like the pro-abortion movement in
that way
um and there's a lot of crossover there
too i imagine and the pro-abortion
movement is is one of the one of the
other most evil movements in
american history so that's one point
second point is that the police i think
should be really careful
about alienating the people who are on
their side
you see videos like that you know if
you're a police officer
as i'm sure you've noticed you don't
have a lot of friends
and it's probably not a good idea to
alienate the few friends you do have
but that's what's going to happen when
we see law-abiding innocent
victims getting arrested like that
and there are others speaking of
alienating the good guys
um let's uh maybe you've seen this
videos from a couple days ago
here's a a christian being arrested
and i believe this is in idaho for
gathering to sing
uh and and praise and worship watch this
our own resources our
enemies have fallen low but we
are held right so save
us
[Music]
you guys should not be doing this and
doing this kind of crap for the mayor
this is embarrassing
you guys are stronger than this
shouldn't be doing this
you guys are tough yeah there was also a
video that's been circulating of a woman
being tased and arrested and cuffed
for what for sitting without a mask on a
you know mostly empty
bleachers at a football game this is the
kind of thing that's going to alienate
the
you know the people that are on your
side the good guys going to alienate
them
with this sort of nonsense number two uh
i love this from charles barkley listen
to this
you know i hear these fools on tv
talking about define the police and
things like that
we need police reform and prison reform
and things like that
because you know who ain't gonna defund
the cops
white neighborhoods and rich
neighborhoods so
that notion they keep saying that i'm
like wait a minute we just gonna leave
who who are black people are supposed to
call ghostbusters when we have crime in
our neighborhoods
we need police reform but like i say
white people
especially rich white people they're
always gonna have cops so we need to
stop that
defund or abolish the cops crap yeah
just basic common sense there
um and what does it tell you
that at this point when somebody is on
tv
saying just basic common sense stuff
all he's really saying is no of course
we don't want to get rid of the police
department are you kidding me
and of course if you're in a
neighborhood that's got more crime
then that's all the more reason why you
want police officers
very basic common sense but what does it
say i appreciate him saying it i don't
mean to
dismiss it or belittle it because it is
important to say but what does it say
about our culture that
someone just making a basic common sense
statement like that is
is such a relief and you are so overcome
with joy just to hear it
you know it's like it's like a just a
fresh cup of water when you've been
wandering in a desert that's what it
feels like
a little cup of water a little cup of
sanity amid the uh
desert of madness so good job
from charles barkley there number three
a few days ago speaking of uh we'll get
back into the madness part of it now
a guy who goes by the name dreadhead
cowboy an activist in chicago he's
worked with
mayor lightfoot uh over there in chicago
is well known for that locally and he
decided to call attention to
the issues by riding a horse down the
highway
in the middle of traffic so here's some
of that you can see you can see him
riding there
all the cops were trailing well now the
dreadhead cowboy is very shocked and
appalled and victimized because
he got arrested for that stunt shocker
of shockers
actually it is kind of a shock that they
arrested someone in chicago for breaking
the law so i appreciate that
but the main charge is animal cruelty um
the animal was ridden almost to death
might still be euthanized it's in
critical condition right he he rode the
animal seven
miles on the pavement without proper
equipment nearly killed it in the
process
all in the name of activism but here he
is now of course
as we know who who's the real victim
here
he blocked traffic rode a horse almost
to death who's the real victim well
it's him and here he is explaining that
and defending his actions in a press
conference listen
my first time ever i'm just gonna go
into i'm an animal lover period
like all my life i've always been an
animal lover and
four years ago it was my first chance
ever been around
a horse and two years later my first
chance
owning a horse and i fell in love with
horses since then
and i owned up to nine horses and when i
say
it's a beautiful thing to own a horse
and i couldn't even tell y'all
the people that don't know anything
about horses from looking for the
outside inn
you would think that what i did was
cruelty to animals
but if you go to the racetrack you
work a hundred times worse when you go
to the turkish
worst they're getting wet i'm sorry okay
um like it's it's way worse than what i
do to my horse i probably could have did
a little bit less but
i had to make a statement they've done
worse at the circus
that's that that's his defense that may
be one of the worst criminal defenses
i've ever heard in my life
they've done worse at the circus
uh maybe if he gets arrested for murder
he can say hey come on you know they
they did worse in the roman coliseum
haven't you seen gladiator come on guys
give me a break
we'll see if that works out for him it
is chicago so maybe it will number four
another one for the get your kids the
hell out of the public schools
file here's a report from the daily wire
it says earlier this summer the fairfax
county public school system in virginia
paid 20
000 to host author ibram kendy for a
virtual event on anti-racism
the left-wing ideology whose adherents
believe it is impossible to
not be racist it's impossible to not be
racist
yet they hold seminars on how to not be
racist
according to a copy of the contract a
link to the
to which was included by journalist azra
nomani
the school district paid 20 000 to the
penguin random house speakers bureau
for a 45-minute virtual event with candy
followed by a 15-minute q a session
school released a statement defending it
saying that um
he's a leading anti-racist voice in
america blah blah blah et cetera
20 grand for one hour online
didn't even have to leave his house now
i admit i
i i am a little salty as the kids would
say i've done some virtual events during
this pandemic
um and i i've been paid for a few of
them i can tell you that
i don't get paid anything close to
twenty thousand dollars for a virtual
event actually it never even occurred to
me to ask for that kind of money
to to sit but you don't have to leave
your house
like here's really the scale if i don't
even have to put on pants
to do the event then i feel like i can't
ask for that kind of money
that's the scale if i have to put on
pants there's going to be an extra
there's going to be charges and fees
that are attached to that and i'll put
that on the invoice of putting on the
pants fee
but when you're just skyping from your
house 20 grand my god
now i ask you to consider this though
reflect on this
is a country oppressing black people
when a black man can get 20 000
to talk about how oppressed he is what
do you think
think about historical examples think
about a you know other
oppressive countries nazi germany the
left often compares the two
uh could people who were oppressed in
nazi germany make thousands of dollars
talking about that oppression
i don't think so so it almost seems like
if you can get paid a lot if you can
make a lot of money in a
certain country going around talking
about how bad the country is to you and
how you're pressed
pretty good indication you're not
oppressed at all and in fact the country
is very kind to you and again
you're doing very well in the country i
don't know
maybe i'm crazy number five finally
important psa for you
black licorice fans out there a
massachusetts man
died last year from eating an excessive
amount of black licorice
doctors said on wednesday the unusual
case was reported in the new england
journal of medicine
detailing how the man consumed a bag and
a half of the candy this is from the new
york post by the way i'm reading
a bag and half of the candy every day
for two weeks prior to his death
licorice contains uh certain
acids and things which can deplete
potassium levels and contribute to heart
rhythm problems
according to doctors so he collapsed
inside a fast food restaurant died the
next day
very sad of course um i will say though
that i i recently discovered that black
licorice is good
um i i and i a lot of people are biased
against black licorice i i think the the
bias is mostly because people
this this is a big problem with food in
general you have your first experience
with black licorice when you're
in childhood right and um when your
palate is unrefined
and you hate anything that isn't sickly
sweet
think about when you're a kid you could
eat like pixie stix
in fact i don't even know if they sell
these anymore probably with all the
public health people out there
they can't but when i was a kid they
used to sell these massive like
garden hose sized pixie sticks
just full of sugar and so you would just
take the garden
hose of of sugar and spray it directly
in your mouth
and i enjoyed that now now i couldn't do
that without vomiting that's because
as your kid your palate isn't quite
developed and you can't you can't deal
with more nuanced
complex flavors and so you try black
licorice you don't like it brussels
sprouts another one
olives liver you gotta go back around as
an adult
and discover that these things are
actually good although apparently
uh they can kill you within two weeks so
that's the downside
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content